this episode was made in collaboration
with Bay Area 415 be sure to check out
their video after this
[Music]
viciously beaten on a New York City
subway the victim was punched in the
face and called an anti-asian slur the
increase in Asian hate crimes across the
country the J train beat
s out after getting punched choked
Plumbing is now charged with a hate
crime and connection with an attack on
the owner of a beauty supply store
disturbing surge of racist attacks
against Asian Americans a 91 year old
man pushed in Oakland's Chinatown one of
three attacks that day 84 year old Thai
American visha ratanapakti knocked over
while out for a walk he died a few days
later from his injuries Asian American
leaders say these attacks are a Trent
not isolated incidents
over the past year the United States has
seen a dramatic surge in violence
against Asian people between March and
December of 2020 there were over 2 800
reports of anti-asian hate and in New
York City alone instances of hate crimes
against Asians skyrocketed by over 800
percent this alarming trend has sparked
a wave of protest and solidarity
movements against anti-asian bigotry and
violence but the problem doesn't seem to
be going away if anything it's getting
worse in this episode we're going to
take a look at the history of anti-asian
prejudice in the U.S and determine why
we're seeing such an explosion of hate
today before we look at the Historical
precedent for this kind of bigotry let's
have a quick look at the current state
of affairs since the beginning of the
coronavirus pandemic certain groups and
Powerful individuals have tried their
best to cast kovid as a Chinese plague
Chinese virus apparently I have the
Wuhan virus kung fu kung fu yeah
while the virus originated in China it
could very easily have come from
anywhere else we should remember that
the so-called Spanish Flu which infected
a full third of the world's population
and killed between 20 and 50 million
people likely originated in the U.S
humans have no say in where an illness
originates all we can do is try to
address the problem when it arises
casting blame doesn't do anyone any good
of course that hasn't stopped U.S
officials from trying to make China look
like the bad guy some even going so far
as to suggest without evidence that the
coronavirus was made in a Chinese lab
Shifting the blame has also allowed the
US to avoid taking responsibility for
our own mishandling of the pandemic
despite having tremendous resources at
our disposal and early warning of the
coming crisis U.S officials dragged
their feet obfuscated lied and we
currently have the most coveted
fatalities by far we made almost no
Provisions for those out of work we
failed to provide emergency Health Care
to our citizens and we now face a
homelessness crisis as those who were
laid off during the pandemic are are
evicted from their homes the coronavirus
pandemic turned out to be very useful to
those in power Trump and Biden share the
same tough on China's stance Biden even
saying recently that China won't take
over on his watch and being able to
blame the pandemic on China has worked
wonders to advance the
military-industrial complex's desire for
war in the name of maintaining our
global economic domination but this
isn't new racism against Asian people
and the weaponization of that racism
have been present in America for well
over a century now the pandemic may have
given people an excuse to act on their
Prejudice but the sentiment has a long
history let's rewind to the 1850s back
in the early days of the construction of
the Transcontinental Railroad
corporations needed labor and they
needed a lot of it but labor could get
expensive at that scale their solution
was to look to China sometimes even
visiting the country themselves to try
to recruit cheap labor in the form of
strong young men who were willing to
come to work on the railroad for less
than their American peers this was
likely the very beginning of anti-asian
Center among Americans from the start
American workers didn't trust their
Chinese counterparts they feared the
Chinese would steal their jobs that
sounds familiar doesn't it periodic
disease outbreaks among the railroad
workers led the Americans to scapegoat
the Chinese workers giving birth to the
notion of Chinese illnesses something
which we see used as a talking point to
this day over the next decade or so
white Americans formed intensely
nativist and racist groups designed to
turn public opinion against the Chinese
in the hopes of keeping America a
Bastion of whiteness the onslaught of
anti-chinese propaganda led
unsurprisingly to violence against
people of Asian Heritage perhaps the
most egregious incident occurred in Los
Angeles in 1871. in what has become
known as the largest mass lynching in
American history 18 Chinese people were
lynched and their homes were burned to
the ground these sorts of attacks would
continue for years and by the end of the
1870s there was enough anti-asian
sentiment in the House and Senate to
consider legislation against Chinese
immigrants in 1882 president Chester A
Arthur signed the now Infamous Chinese
Exclusion Act which was the first and
only law to completely ban the
immigration of a certain ethnicity or
National Group into the United States
not only did this legislation prevent
new Chinese immigrants from coming in it
also permanently banned naturalization
for those nearly two hundred thousand
Chinese who already lived in America so
those workers who had toiled endlessly
doing back-breaking work for low wages
to build the massive wealth of railroad
magnets and create the backbone of U.S
infrastructure were not allowed to
become citizens in the country they
helped to build to make matters worse
the Chinese Exclusion Act was
functionally a family separation policy
those who had come to the U.S to earn
enough money to bring their loved ones
over were now stranded they would never
be allowed back in if they chose to
leave their families couldn't join them
in the states and those Chinese
immigrants who were unmarried were
legally banned from marrying white women
most Americans today aren't aware of
just how horrific and racist this
legislation was we literally said we
only want white people here Europeans
come on over but you Chinese are not
welcome of course this still wasn't
enough for the nativist groups of the
time the violence against Asians
continued we saw hideous acts like the
Rock Springs massacre in 1885 in which
white miners brutally mutilated and
killed as many as 50 people the
following year in Seattle over 200
Chinese people were taken from their
homes forced onto boats and expelled
from the city with nowhere to go while
the Chinese Exclusion Act set the stage
for over a century of continued
anti-asian bigotry it was by no means
the last piece of official legislation
used to codify racism in the U.S in 1924
the Immigration Act expanded our
race-based immigration policies to the
rest of Asia effectively banning all
Asians from entering the country it also
sets strict quotas for admission of
immigrants from the Eastern Hemisphere
the enforcement of which
disproportionately affected Italians
Greeks poles Slavs and Eastern European
Jews the official reasoning for this
absurdly xenophobic legislation was was
a quote to preserve the ideal of U.S
homogeneity this law was so Draconian
that it was cited by none other than
Adolf Hitler as being personally
inspirational to him and it would later
inform his own policies the 1924
Immigration Act served to reinforce
racist policy at the highest levels
enshrining the notion of whiteness in
federal law it wasn't until 1943 that
Chinese people were allowed to set foot
in the country again and even then we
only let in 105 people per year it would
take another nine years before the
direct racial bans were lifted it was
1965 before the National Origins
immigration formula was scrapped some of
you watching this or more likely your
parents were probably alive when Asian
people were not allowed to enter this
country simply because of their race now
simple bigotry under the guise of
protecting some misguided notion of
whiteness is one thing but there is
another type of anti-asian racism that
is even more hideous in each instance of
conflict with an Asian Nation or of
pursuing imperialist goals in Asia the
United States has deployed a vicious
propaganda campaign to encourage hatred
or dehumanization of Asians among the
American population in China Vietnam
Korea Laos every time the U.S is
involved in Asia racism is deployed as a
weapon to justify U.S aggression once
upon a time when we were ransacking
China along with the other Imperial
Powers we manufactured the caricature of
China as the sick man of Asia afflicted
by addiction laziness and poverty this
of course ignored the fact that
imperialist meddling had caused those
problems through the Opium Wars
despicable trade policies and the
dismemberment of China into foreign
concessions and colonies this was back
when China was a fairly weak Nation
compared to the U.S fast forward to
today and China is a growing economic
superpower on track to surpass the U.S
in a matter of years this is where the
link between manufactured racism and U.S
imperialist goals should become more
obvious for many years China and Chinese
people and people from other Asian
countries by extension were viewed as
weak submissive and morally lacking now
that China is a strong country capable
of forging its own global economic
alliances the U.S has to frame the
propaganda in a different way the
Chinese are still a threat but this time
not because they will weaken the
American population with their moral
decrepitude but because they could
destroy our way of life by usurping the
mantle of the world's greatest economic
power that's why we are seeing such a
dramatic rise in anti-china news
coverage and as usually follows
propaganda campaigns a rise in hate
crimes against the targeted group
because China is offering other nations
an alternative the U.S has maintained
global economic domination the U.S
dollar is the world currency and we can
threaten any recalcitrant nations with
vicious and crippling sanctions China is
reaching the point where they can say
hey we'll work with you instead before
China's rise to economic prominence the
only way countries could receive loans
to develop their infrastructure would be
through the IMF or the World Bank which
would force harsh conditions on
developing countries to pay back their
loans through privatizing their service
to the people and pushing for austerity
measures China is now capable of
offering those same countries view to no
conditions for these loans and
negotiates with them as equals through
their policy of win-win diplomacy
American leadership does not want this
to happen the U.S is facing an economic
challenge greater than they did during
the Cold War and they're trying to bring
back the same old Red Scare propaganda
for good measure the tools U.S officials
and mainstream media are using in this
most recent campaign are from the same
old Playbook caricatures of
disease-bearing Chinese because of the
coronavirus the China virus the Kung Fu
these more obviously racist terms are
more prevalent among the American
Republicans but there are plenty of
Democrats who will insinuate the same
thing more often though they'll make
claims of sneaky Chinese hackers trying
to subvert our strong democracy this is
a more palatable bit of propaganda to
the Democrats because it doesn't sound
like an outright attack on the inherent
characteristics of all Asian people they
tried the same thing with Russia and
with Iran but you don't have to look
very hard to find the explicit reasoning
for the anti-china campaign in April of
2019 a state department official said
this is a fight with a really different
civilization and a different ideology
it's the first time that we will have a
great power competitor that is not
Caucasian there it is the part you're
not supposed to say out loud this time
is different because they're not white
and we wonder why there's been a spike
in anti-asian hate crimes when these
people are in power now at this point
you should be aware that if you turn on
the news you're pretty much guaranteed
to see at least one negative story about
China the propaganda machine is spinning
at full speed desperately trying to
manufacture our consent for war but
let's be charitable here let's see if
there's any justification for U.S
aggression towards China could the spike
in anti-asian hate be a necessary
byproduct of U.S self-defense short
answer no but let's take a look at some
of the claims the U.S makes about China
claim number one they're a direct and
impending military threat as I mentioned
in a previous video the U.S doesn't
really have anything to worry about when
it comes to military conflict we spend
more on the military than the next 10
Nations combined and even if we cut our
spending in half we'd still spend a
hundred billion dollars more per year
than China regardless calling China an
impending military threat is more than a
little ironic unlike the US which has
been in a state of constant War for
decades China has waged exactly one war
outside its own borders in recent memory
and that was a brief border Skirmish
with Vietnam in 1979. in the past 40
years China has not had a single foreign
military offensive whereas the U.S has
staged coups invaded occupied and
outright demolished many countries
during that same period it should be
clear which nation is the bigger threat
to the rest of the world since this
first claim won't really hold up to much
scrutiny the only other alternative is
to stoke outrage at purported human
rights violations whether or not these
claims are true I don't believe for one
second that the U.S actually cares about
human rights at this very moment in my
home state we have immigrant families
crammed into holding cells at the border
family members separated from one
another no coveted precautions being
taken we've even seen evidence that ice
has performed forced sterilizations on
some of these people this is only part
of a long history of U.S human rights
abuses against certain races we did the
same thing to Japanese Americans in
World War II locking up our own citizens
in internment camps American soldiers
have committed innumerable war crimes by
subjecting prisoners to unspeakable
torture in Abu ghraib we've overthrown
democratically elected governments and
installed puppet dictators directly
leading to the death of thousands our
military action in just the last two
decades has killed millions and
displaced tens of millions the cherry on
top is the fact that xinjiang America's
number one target for claims of Human
Rights abuses against Muslims is right
next door to Afghanistan a country we
have bombed into Oblivion where we have
cast Muslims as vicious terrorists for
deca decades a group of people we have
tried to ban from entering our country
now people absolutely should speak up
about human rights abuses wherever they
occur but if the United States wants to
point fingers we need to start with the
biggest offender in modern history the
US government's claims of Human Rights
abuses have nothing to do with genuine
concern it's simply another way to
manufacture consent for a war to
maintain our economic Stranglehold on
the rest of the world
so what are the takeaways here when you
remove the history of U.S imperialism
and racism against non-white Nations and
peoples the current wave of anti-asian
sentiment seems to have come out of
nowhere but if you put it in its
historical context as part of a long
campaign of dehumanization of perceived
Outsiders during an escalating cold war
with China it makes perfect sense this
is not happening in a vacuum there are
geopolitical and imperialist projects at
work that require and promote a level of
prejudice among the American population
what we are seeing now is a repackaging
of very old Prejudice for a new moment
the U.S has produced specific
anti-chinese anti-japanese
anti-vietnamese propaganda in the past
and each time the general population has
failed to distinguish between those
ethnicities each era had its own General
anti-asian hate regardless of the
intended target nationality the same is
happening today the U.S government and
the corporate media are manufacturing
hatred for China and because racism
lacks sophistication that hatred is is
spilling over in the mind of the public
to include members of the entire Asian
diaspora if you're against Asian hate
you must stand against war and U.S
imperialism the U.S weaponizes racism
and xenophobia to achieve its foreign
policy goals those goals being the
subjugation and exploitation of other
nations particularly in the global South
at the end of the day stop Asian hate is
insufficient as a rallying cry it takes
a systemic problem one reinforced by the
entire strength of the U.S war machine
and mainstream media and turns it into a
personal problem it posits if each of us
can just stop being racist the problem
will go away the thing is it's not a
personal problem it's a problem that's
been manufactured and incited by a
global superpower that needs the consent
of its people to engage in catastrophic
War we need to recognize the systemic
and structural forces at work resist the
urge to buy into propaganda and remember
that war and hatred never benefit normal
people only those at the very top
if you'd like to hear some other
perspectives on the topic of Asian hate
and U.S imperialism check out Bay Area
415's companion video they've got a
great panel of guests each with their
own valuable insights on this critical
topic if you enjoyed this video consider
dropping a like if you hated it a thumbs
down you can check out my previous
videos by clicking the links on your
screen thanks for watching and I'll see
you next week
[Music]